all right well we might as well get
started it's 301 um yeah so everyone
knows what's happening here
in this section in general we're going
to have the ccsi fellows
really delighted to have all of them
okay yeah
thank you guys so hello everyone what's
up soon my name is
and i recently graduated from stanford
double e and currently i'm assuming a
fellow at the family institute so the
title of my talk will be the fundamental
limits and optimal uses of data in
modern learning problems so this title
may seem that it's been large but this
is precisely what my research focus was
lights on so specifically yeah my
research aims to understand the
information radio complexity of
different learning problems in various
in various fields and this task is
two-folded so first would like to derive
fundamental limits of a given learning
problem understand where is the
bottleneck of problem and
how slight changes in the problem
formulation will drastically change the
final result
and on the other side on the other hand
would also like to basically propose the
ultimate algorithm matching achieving a
performance matching the fundamental
limit
so this is basically a play between
upper and lower bounds and this is
reflected in the following example this
example may not be the most technically
most challenging one nor the practically
practically most significant ones but
this in this example we will see how the
play between the upper and lower about
holes in this specific problem
so this problem is called the unified
estimation of discrete functions so
what's that problem what's the s problem
so in discrete functional estimation we
just mean by given id observations x1 to
xn following a discrete distribution key
with the process k with we'd like to
estimate the quantity capital f of p
which is the sum of little f over p i
for d for a given function f so in this
problem we have two parameters n is the
sample size okay the support size and we
will take little f to be different
functions with the cover here some
widely used examples that have general
entropy support site and so on and this
problem also has a lot of applications
and generalizations
and
so in the past decade yeah there has
been a lot of research focused on this
specific type of problem and where a
large body of literature is devoted to
the problem so called the ad hoc
estimation which means that okay we
would like to we first knows with the
target function and then we would have
to propose a given estimator for that
function
so the main result of that line of
research is that the most natural
estimator which is the plugin approach
or the traditional mle where we simply
plug in plug the empirical distribution
of the samples into the target
functional turns out to be strictly
suboptimal and specifically yes they
showed a phenomenon called the effective
sample size enlargement meaning that the
of the performance of the electrical
estimate of the samples is
essentially the performance of the mle
and logan samples and this enlargement
phenomenon is actually supported in lots
of this meditation yeah on the line of
ad hoc estimation
but this is not our focus
we aim to understand even a more
ambitious topic called a unified
estimation so what's our target
we'd like to find a single distribution
estimate of p hat such that would like
to plug the same p hat into different
functions and we hope that
the final estimator could be universally
optimal for many side functions so as a
pictorial illustration basically the
estimator p hat only depends on the
observations x and x and and we will use
the same p hat to estimate different
functions
so this task yeah is of course ambitious
and it may sound too good to be true
yeah at least due to two reasons first
the natural estimator the empirical
distribution is yeah fails to do a two
to the drop and secondly so even for
ad-hoc estimation typically people have
already derived very complicated
procedures even for estimating a single
function so it might be a little bit
hard to propose a unified one that works
for many of them
and a
next question is that okay are there any
fundamental penalties of a unified
destination compared to an ad hoc
attention question guys
for example three could be different
literate functions for example they're
taken from any
class of one literature
yeah but we need to use the same key
hand that's the point
okay
okay so surprisingly for this task
actually we could at least provide two
different approaches that do the job of
a unified destination
so for the first approach is called the
local moment matching proposed by us in
2018 where we directly look at that
problem and disputely construct a single
estimator based on the idea of mobile
matching doing that locally yeah and we
could show that that estimator could
attain the optimal sample capacity for
large class of symmetric functionals but
with an additional condition that is the
accuracy parameter absolute much must
exceed some threat called n to the power
minus one certain
okay so this is uh one yeah one problem
here and the second approach well
totally independent of us is called the
profile maximum likelihood or pml in
chart
so we start with the definition of a
profile basically given in samples we
are taking value in a discrete domain
the profile is a n dimensional vector v
one to three n where v i is the number
of domain elements appearing exactly i
times for example when our samples are a
b a c the v y is equal to two because
there are two symbols appearing once and
the fifth rib to one because there is
one symbol a which is a appearing three
times in the sample
and after the definition of a profile
yeah it was proposed by olyssky at all
in 2004 actually very old estimator yeah
yeah
yeah we defined the profile maximum
likelihood just similar to the
traditional mle the profile likelihood
estimator is simply the distribution
which maximizes the prof the likelihood
of a given profile fee
and
yeah in the previous example we could
see yeah basically the likelihood will
be proportional to this expression so
the maximization program is very
different from the traditional mle and
you could see that it may be very hard
to compute or even approximate because
this is a sum of exponentially many
non-convex terms right okay and yeah for
the computational burden they are
very recently there are some probably
polynomial kind of approximate
algorithms to do that and it was also
very challenging to establish this
statistical property so in 2017 around
the same time of the
our local movement banking work yeah a
dia acharya does elicit and stress shows
that okay plug in the pml distribution
can also attain the rate optimal sample
complexity for large class of functions
provided another condition where epsilon
is much greater than the circle of n to
the power minus a quarter
so to sum up we have three different
approaches ad hoc local moment matching
and pml
and ad-hoc approach could achieve the
full optimality will never have epsilon
greater than one over two than the
parametric rate but for the the latter
of two approaches yeah
are only universally optimal given some
condition either instruments around the
earth or into the final one quarter
so the the pml authors actually ask the
following open problem they will ask
whether the requirement absolutely
greater than the power of minor power
and force and add effect of that their
analysis or just a fundamental burden of
that pml
so we answer this to this question in
two aspects so first
without some hard effort we could
actually improve the analysis of pml
this we improve threshold to n to the
power one minus one so
okay yeah after half effort actually we
could improve that and then we see that
oh why do these two approaches share the
same threshold
and and because these two approaches are
totally independent of each other
actually at least from the
the ideas are very different
and so we move on to uh to ask the first
the second question is there are some
fundamental limitations of all possible
unified approaches
surprisingly the answer is yes and unto
the minus one third is the tax threshold
for all types of unified approaches
basically that
problem exhibits a very interesting
threshold which is n to the power of
power minus one third above which the
universal activation is possible yeah
and are achieved by both local movement
and the gmail but below that yeah the it
is it is approvally impossible and we
could also show a very tight adapter
basically uh tighter separation a tight
gap adaptation gap for those problems so
this is basically this is uh
this is the example i'd like to show
about how to play between the upper and
the lower bounds
so in so in general yeah i'd also like
to mention on this yeah briefly mention
some of my past research so just for the
introduction introduction purposes yeah
some other research that i'm very
excited about include including a very
recent work in about optimal bidding in
first place options basically in theory
yeah we would like to overcome some very
interesting some practical phenomenon
called some essential feedback or some
other environment of yeah
frequently appearing in practice and
most importantly we like to provide a
timely solution to practical advertisers
and demand side platforms after a very
recent industrial shift and our
algorithm is currently actually used in
the already media yeah the massive
transfer
and almost the right theoretical side we
are also doing some continuous entropy
estimation problems and we completely
settled the
highly minimalist rate of estimating the
the entropy of a given density and
importantly without assuming the density
is bounded away from zero
and and similarly for other research
including okay how to understand the
effects of asthmatic district functional
understand the effect of the spectral
gap in learning markov chains understand
okay what is the role of limited amount
of interaction in bandit and
reinforcement learning how what is the
effect of the privacy or communication
constraint in federation learning yeah
yeah what what knowledge could the
known translation provide us in
invitation learning and what is the
difference between let's say learning
and the sample application and so on
so basically my
pro research profile is about is yeah
the core is on learning and to myself i
care about optimality and also i'm
interested in in many interdisciplinary
problems so so here i'm looking forward
to
working with great people from different
fields also from working on different
very
great problems also spending in all
areas thank you
any questions
well is
thanks again